(serious hip hop music)
- Well welcome to another
episode of The Addy Hour,
we've had a little bit of hiatus,
but excited to jump into
these conversations again,
and today we're gonna be talking about
race, politics, religion,
and mental health in America.
So some heavy topics,
but some important topics
and really excited for two guests
that I have on the program today.
The first that I'd like to introduce,
I'm honored to be able to welcome
professor Eddie Glaude
Jr. to The Addy Hour.
As many of you probably already know,
Dr. Glaude is one of the
nation's most prominent scholars.
He's an author, a political commentator,
a public intellectual,
and a passionate educator
who examines the complex dynamics
of the American experience.
Dr. Glaude is the James S. McDonnell
distinguished university professor
and chair of the department
of African-American studies at Princeton.
He's a Morehouse graduate who also holds
a master's degree in
African-American studies from Temple
and a PhD in religion from Princeton.
Dr. Glaude is someone who is
a columnist for Time magazine,
he's also a regular contributor
on programs like Morning Joe,
Deadline: White House with Nicolle Wallace
and Meet the Press.
And he's someone who
continually challenges us
to examine our collective
American conscience,
and in his words, to not to
posit the greatness of America,
but to establish the ground upon which
to imagine the country anew.
So I'm honored and thrilled
to be able to welcome
professor Glaude to The
Addy Hour this morning.
Thanks for being here.
- It's my pleasure, looking forward to it.
- Looking forward to it as well.
My next guest I'd like to introduce
is none other than A.D. Lumkile Thomason,
who is a speaker, poet, and
an award winning filmmaker.
He's spoken around the United States
and in places like Sudan, South Africa,
China, and Palestine, and
he's also the author of
Permission to be Black: My
Journey with Jay Z and Jesus,
where he acknowledges and confronts
the reality of racial
trauma and shares his story
to give permission to readers
to be black, to be Christian,
and to be the person
God has made them to be.
A.D. is a native of Detroit,
he has more than 17 years of experience
preaching and teaching the peace of Jesus
in ethnically divided countries,
cultures, and communities,
and so I'm honored to be able to welcome
A.D. to the podcast today,
thanks for being here.
- It's good to be here.
Excited.
- I know we were joking offline too,
I didn't get the memo about the
coordination with the shirt,
so I'm still feeling
a little bit left out,
but I think hopefully, you know,
as we roll with this conversation,
I'll feel a sense of belonging
and inclusion as well.
(all chuckling)
Just, you know, just
to start out, you know,
the topics obviously we're
gonna be talking about
are heavy, and these are
topics that you all talk about
on a regular basis, and I
really appreciate the way
both of you are public scholars
and have really helped us
to continue to think about
our history as a nation,
our present and our future.
But one of the things I just
want to do to start out,
and listeners know that
we often just like to
check in and see how people are doing,
but I'm curious to know with the topics
that you all engage
in, how do you continue
to engage in those topics
while also taking time
to kind of watch your
own emotional wellness,
balance your time management,
work-life balance,
all those things.
How do you that on a day to day basis?
Dr. Glaude, if we could
start out with you?
- It's a challenge, you know,
because I find myself having to comment,
almost every day, on the state
of the country, you know.
You know, I'm being asked
to interpret the drums,
as Adolph Reed would say.
And so, you know, in my work I talk about
finding your elsewhere,
a place that allows you
to get the requisite distance
from the reality of the world.
And so, you know, you gotta have
those people who love you unconditionally.
So I just flew down to Memphis
and hung out with my boys
that I've been, I've known
since my Morehouse days,
we all just met there and just
had an extraordinary time.
You know, I disappear into novels.
I'm finishing, I just
finished a wonderful novel
by Anna Burns entitled Milkman,
and then I re-read The
Parable of the Sower
by Octavia Butler, and
now I'm finishing up
Shuggie Bain by Douglas
Stuart, so you know,
just kind of disappear
into fiction in some ways.
So, you know, finding a respite
in friends and in novels,
that's been the way I've been
keeping my head on my shoulders.
- That's great.
And it sounds so intentional too.
I mean, even the time that
you spend reading books,
hanging out with folks,
I imagine, you know,
that takes time too, so
I'm impressed that you're,
you carve out the time for that.
Do you ever get any pushback
in terms of, you know,
why are you not available
for this and that?
Or, I mean, how have you navigated that?
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
everybody, you know,
once you acquire a certain
kind of public standing,
you know, everybody thinks that they,
everyone's asking for your time.
And so you just have to be very deliberate
about being able to
carve out your own time
and being able to cultivate
the capacity to say no.
And I needed, you know,
because I'm the chair of
a department, you know,
I'm public, you know, I'm
traveling around the country,
I'm doing television, I'm writing.
I just needed, you know,
you gotta replenish
because this is not a sprint.
This is a long distance race.
So you gotta be able to at least
carve out some time for yourself.
So some people might be
annoyed when I say no,
but you know, we try to
say it in a generous way.
Like I was, like I got
home training, you know.
- Yeah, I think that's so important.
I think that's encouraging
for others to hear too,
'cause I think sometimes
people look at folks like you
and they're like, how did they do that?
How did they balance that all?
How do they keep going?
So to be able to hear kind
of that behind the scenes
and know there are times
that you're saying no
and really focusing on what you need to do
to stay in that place, I
think that's really important.
- Absolutely, doc.
- A.D., what about you?
- Yeah, I mean, it's, I'll make it,
I'll simplify it to just
say I try to connect
with nature in silence.
To me silence rejuvenates me, you know,
so some tangible things I'll do,
I'll go fishing and turn
the phone off, you know,
and I could be out there
from sun up to sun down
just in my thoughts, 12 hours a day.
I got a bow, so I do bow hunting
and I'm out there doing
archery in the woods
and target and it's good.
It's, you know, I do read,
I like film, you know,
like that fiction, that can remind me of
the possibility of what
could be despite what is,
you know, so aspirational things.
And yeah, you got to connect with people
who have a like-mind,
but they don't want anything from you.
I think that's the rare reality
is finding people who don't want anything
or won't turn the
conversation in their favor,
but they just like your presence.
So those are probably the
things that I would do.
Or I do.
- That's definitely good.
Is that something that
you've done from the get-go
or were these things that you'd say
you developed over time out of necessity?
- Definitely over time out of necessity.
You know, you look at different characters
in the history from, you know,
you take the Dalai Lama
going on in creation
or Gandhi, King, you know, Christ himself.
You just see, there's something
with creation in silence.
You know, and like, you
know, we'll say it earlier,
like, you know, people will
steal that time if you let them.
So you have to have a discipline,
a muscle of saying no in a
kind way to replenish yourself.
- Yeah, I think that's so good.
I wanted to bring it home to
students a little bit too,
'cause you know just in my experience
working with students, I
mean I'm always encouraged
by their passion and how willing they are
to jump in to so many important topics
and conversations and
fights, to be honest,
in a lot of ways.
And I see that really with the, you know,
the generation coming up.
But then at the same time sometimes,
like you all were both talking about,
I don't always see the
willingness to say no.
And so people get themselves
spread really thin
and especially with the emotional
toll that comes with it,
not always having time
to kind of step back
and take care of themselves,
or if mental health challenges come up
really not having the tools
to address those types of things.
I'm curious, not even
just in terms of timing
but in terms of topics, how do you all
decide what topics to engage in
and when to pull back and say, okay,
you know, I'm passionate about this
but this is something that right now
I just need to make sure I
don't spread myself too thin
and just go a thousand miles an hour,
or like pick which battles to engage in?
Professor Glaude, you want to?
- You know I, you know, the
temptation in this world,
particularly in the world of punditry,
is that you can speak
on everything, you know,
and you know, A.D.'s point about silence
is really, really key, right?
Sometimes you just have to, you know,
understand that this is not your lane.
You know, I can talk about
this, I have opinions on it,
but this is really not
where my expertise lies,
so why am I talking?
Right?
And so a lot of times I
find myself, you know,
making decisions based upon, you know,
somebody else could be, somebody
else might be better here.
Why do I need to occupy this space?
Right?
Open it up for someone else.
Let someone else step in there.
So, you know, I make
decisions on the one hand,
you know, around what I know.
What's my value-add to the conversation?
How might I frame it different?
On the other hand, and then
there's another, you know,
what, I'm not a guy who wants
to talk about, you know,
popular culture a lot, right?
So, you know, I'm not
the one you're gonna call
to talk about Jay Z or DMX
or, you know, or Cardi B.
That's not my zone, right?
So again, knowing where you are, right?
So what does it mean when I'm being asked
to reflect on a movie or a film
or a popular cultural event?
Understanding where I am
and trying to be consistent
with who I am, right?
So I think part of it
has everything to do,
both of those points have everything to do
with being consistent, trying
to be consistently clear
about the purpose of your
voice and why you're speaking.
What is your platform for?
How does it relate to your calling?
And when you ask yourself those questions,
then you're not pursuing opportunities
in order to cultivate brand.
- That's good.
- You see, 'cause you're doing something
that is more than just simply
you running your mouth.
So that becomes the basis of
making these sorts of choices.
'Cause if not, somebody asks
you to talk about anything,
anything and everything, and you know,
it's this, something
happens to black people,
what do you think black people think?
(all chuckling)
Right?
So, 'cause you're the
interpreter of black folk,
you know, so you've gotta be
very deliberate in this regard.
- Yeah, I think that's so good
from the standpoint of the speaker.
I'm a little bit curious
because how do we,
I'm curious what you
think about how people
should filter that as
consumers, in a sense,
'cause as a speaker you have control
about whether you step
into a conversation or not.
Granted there are a lot of people
who are stepping out of their lane
and still speaking into conversations.
So from the receiving end, like how do we,
how do we filter that?
And just not get taken up by everything
that everyone has said
about every single topic?
- Well, you know, this
is one of the challenges,
I'll just say this real quickly
and then I'll shut up, right?
One of the challenges
about our current moment
is that there's a kind of
leveling that happens, right?
The kind of disappearance of expertise,
and so because of social
media platforms and the like,
everybody can be an expert
on anything and everything.
And so you have to be a kind
of discerning listener, right?
How do you absorb information?
How do you, who do you
extend authority to, right?
What material are you drawing on
in order to form your opinion?
So I think part of what we
have to do in this moment,
where seriousness is under attack,
is cultivate the habits of
listening intelligently, right?
Cultivate the habits of acquiring
a kind of ruthless orientation
to what you take in,
because as we're taking in
all this information, man,
we're also taking in a lot of toxins.
I mean you on Twitter for just 15 minutes
and you just kind like,
damn, I need to go brush my,
I need to go take a bath or something,
'cause there's just a lot of negativity
just kind of coming at you
over and over and over again.
So there's, the implication
of that leveling is that,
you know, everybody thinks
they know everything,
when hardly anybody's reading these days
or they're reading at the surface.
So you have to become a much
more discerning listener
and choose who you're
going to lend authority to
as opposed to just
accepting everybody's voice.
- Yeah, yeah that's true.
A.D., before we swing back
just to your filtering,
I'm just curious, also in
your role as a professor,
'cause some of the topics
that you teach about,
you know, about human rights,
decolonizing your faith,
filmmaking and things like that,
are there ways that
you guide your students
through that filtering process?
Because those topics too,
I'm assuming that you're deconstructing
a lot of presuppositions
as you get into that.
So I feel like a lot of these topics
would likely come up in
the classroom for you.
- Yeah, I mean, that's
a good way to say it,
deconstructing people's presuppositions.
Man, that is a hard task (laughs).
'Cause when people have
presupposed and concluded,
they'll see that in anything,
even if it's not there.
So I think people have, one
they have a fear of missing out.
You know, and because they have
such a fear of missing out,
they'll take in the toxic and the healthy,
but the problem is they don't know
how to distinguish between
the two anymore, you know?
So now people are becoming experts
just on being up on the trash, right?
(laughs) You know, that's the new thing.
Whereas before, in our
generation, we actually wanted
to go to the expert because
they put in the time,
not because they were charismatic
or et cetera, et cetera.
So kind of lost that.
So what I challenge my students on
is having a grind, a work
ethic to dig, you know,
and a lot of people
just don't want to dig.
They wanna, they have
a fear of missing out
and then they don't want to dig,
and when you got social media
it gives you the best of all of that.
When you're lazy and you
don't want to miss out,
you're like I just take in
whatever comes my way, right?
And we know that that
doesn't make a, I would call
an honest intellectual,
an honest pundit, right?
It just makes one who
becomes now personalities.
And so that's what I challenge them,
I'll say are you gonna be
a person or a personality?
Yeah.
- I like that.
- Yeah, that's good.
How do the students react with that?
- It's good, I mean it's good.
It's refreshing for
them actually, you know,
'cause no one is challenging
them on that, you know.
I think what Eddie said earlier is good.
Who you give authority to.
It's almost like, why do you give
your authority away so easily?
(laughs) What, now tell me what they did?
Oh, they got a 10 time platinum record,
so that's why you follow what
they say on civil rights?
No!
(all laughing)
Obviously I'm being
facetious, but that's what,
you got to show them their
broken philosophy sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's really good.
To push on that a little bit though,
I mean I'm thinking of
the flip side of that too.
What do you think about, you know,
the situations where people are kind of
sharing from their lived experience?
So, you know, thinking back to LeBron
and the just shut up and
dribble type of comment.
How do we balance those two sides of it?
'Cause I think you're right.
At one hand, if someone's
a platinum selling artist
it doesn't mean that they
have put in the grind
on certain components,
but at the same time,
we have the flip side
where people are just
invalidating people speaking
into these social issues
when they, I mean, how,
what do you all think about that line?
How do we balance that?
- All right, let me
give a Dwayne Wade live
to Eddie on this one.
So I am not a proponent
of shut up and dribble
in its connotation,
but I am when you haven't done the work.
And I'm gonna tell you why.
Because what happens is they'll
give authority to a LeBron
who hasn't read anything
and then millions of people
start walking it out.
Like, yeah man, see what we gotta do is
we just gotta say F the police, man,
you know not that LeBron said that,
but when people start talking
and they haven't done the actual work,
then you're swaying culture in a way
with that lack of work ethic.
- So, you know, just to pick up that,
'cause I'm gonna take
it and do this with it.
(all laughing)
There are examples of courage
that abound in everyday life,
and people who have a lot to lose
when they exhibit that
courage is worth lifting up.
So when someone says shut up and dribble
and you respond, that is a moment, right?
Where, you know, LeBron James thought more
about himself as a man, as a human being,
than himself as a kind of
product, as a basketball player.
But it doesn't follow from that, right,
that now LeBron or Jay Z for that matter
can step into, you know,
the, the brouhaha over,
for example, the national
anthem and the NFL.
And suddenly because you are a businessman
and you have this cachet that
you can enter into that space
and suddenly resolve everything
that Colin Kaepernick
was trying to do.
And the folk around him
were trying to do, right?
So I think it's really important
just to pick up on A.D.'s point right,
that examples of courage are important,
but they come, it also comes with,
when we talk about moving
from a moment to a movement,
it also requires a kind
of depth of learning.
So, you know, and people are influential
in a number of different areas,
whether they're in sport,
whether they're in academe,
whether they're in the business world,
whether there's your uncle or your aunt,
folks are influential, but
it doesn't necessarily,
just because they're
influential in one moment
doesn't mean that they're
influential in all moments.
- See, that's good.
You catch that?
(all laughing)
Did you catch that?
And I'm gonna, again, I'm
gonna do another move,
I'll pass it back.
And here's what I think people
miss in what he's saying,
we don't pass the ball to
the right person anymore.
We assume we're supposed
to take the shot, right?
You see what I'm saying?
So if I know Eddie has put in his work
and they ask him something
on politics, I go,
yeah, I can give
insightful, but I go, nah,
I'm gonna pass it to him.
And we don't see people in those platforms
have the right relationships
to pass to the right person
or at least be mentored
by the right person
that they should be passing to.
Right?
So my question be like why isn't a LeBron
being mentored by the
Eddie Glaudes in the world
so when they ask him that
question, he's like, bam,
I know what to do.
- Well, you know, I would hope
that he has some folks in his camp.
I pray that he does.
(all chuckling)
But you know, I think it's really,
I think that's a really important point.
It goes back to something
I said earlier, A.D.,
and that, you know, the
temptation is to hog the mic.
That, you know, you think you can,
just because you got it you
suppose to speak on everything.
And the discipline, the
spiritual discipline actually,
to actually be quiet and pass the mic
is something that we have to cultivate.
- That's good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I like that.
- Wow, that's so true.
I think the challenge
is actually cultivating,
getting to that point,
helping people cultivate that.
I mean, I think it's refreshing
to hear both of you espouse that here.
I'm just, I guess I'm trying to,
how does that work out practically?
- Let me give you an example,
let me give you a practical example.
Bob Moses, God bless his soul,
you know, I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for what Bob
Moses did in Mississippi,
you know, I'm a country boy
from Moss Point, Mississippi.
SNCC was in Moss point, Hollis Watkins,
I mean, Stokely
Carmichael, all these folk,
and Ms. Ella Baker told the SNCC folk,
you know, shut up and listen,
maybe you might learn something.
As they were organizing sharecrop.
And so Bob's orientation
was to entrance into spaces
and create the conditions under which
indigenous leadership would emerge,
'cause he was saying
we are the leaders we've been looking for.
And so at the heart of his politics
is a politics of tending.
Tending to the person
right in front of you.
Tending to the situation
right in front of you,
which means you have to have
the habits of listening,
you have to be perceptive,
you have to be empathetic,
all of these things.
So at the heart of SNCC, as
a civil rights organization,
right, is moving into
spaces that people thought
were at the margins of American
democratic life, right?
And creating the conditions under which
a Fannie Lou Hamer could emerge.
- Come on.
- You see what I mean?
So part of what we have to do,
oftentimes in this culture
and this moment now,
we're so preoccupied with
our own individual brands,
we're so preoccupied with projecting,
or as we would say getting
something on consignment
so we can then get our hustle.
I'm going a little too deep there-
- No, go man (laughs).
- Give me this so that I
can do this, and you know,
'cause we all want to
get in the game, right?
Not understanding what really,
what we're trying to do really
is change the game entirely.
And that's gonna require not folk
getting out front necessarily,
but all of us kind of
creating the conditions
under which each and every other person
can become the fullest human being
that they're called to
be, if that makes sense.
- No that's good.
So to answer your question
directly, 'cause I-
- Alley-oop.
(all laughing)
- He wants some tangibles,
I can see the neural science in his brain,
he's like man I need some 10 steps.
(all laughing)
- Can't hide it.
- You know, I think we've been
fortunate to know our story,
to look at our story, what
are some resonating things?
So if I were to say
something to people I'd say
write out your story.
Where did you grow up?
Mom, dad, what's their story?
Siblings, no siblings, the environment,
if you fortunate, college,
you know, masters, doctorate.
Write out, and you'll start to see themes.
And going back to Eddie's point earlier,
when you see those themes,
you'll know what you're
supposed to be saying yes to.
And the problem is, people don't know
the theme of their life.
So for me, my theme is
storytelling, integrity,
and fighting for those who are oppressed.
Those are my themes.
So I know what to say yes to,
and I know what to say no to.
I know what to pass to, even if someone
gives me an opportunity
I'm gonna pass, right?
And recommend someone else.
I think a lot of people
don't know themselves.
And I would even say this,
a lot of people may know themselves,
they want to be something else
because of the glory
that may come with it.
So now we talking about humility.
You see what I'm saying?
Everybody, you know it's
funny when people read
like things on MLK or
things on like the Gandhi's
or the, you know, even Christ himself,
they always read themselves
as MLK, Gandhi, Christ.
They never read themselves
as the secondary,
third, or the person on
the side of the road.
But a lot of us may be the onlooker
who's trying to get the
courage to be that person.
And that's okay.
It's okay if you're the tiller
and the one who plants the seed
and never brings in the
harvest, but your work matters.
- Yeah, that's good.
I mean, two themes I'm hearing
coming out from both of you,
just community and purpose.
So you know, as you're talking about,
just tending to the people
and the building of the community,
and here comes the neuroscience, A.D.,
you be pulled it out, but
just the importance of that
for our brains in general
and what that does.
So many people talk a lot
about oxytocin and other things
that we have when we're in community
and social interactions with
others and how that helps us
get to a place of peace
and how it makes us more
effective in what we do
on a day to day basis.
And A.D., as you're bringing out
just all the aspects of purpose
and how that guides what you
say yes to, what you say no to.
I mean, I think those pieces,
both of those are really
important and critical
guiding pieces for people moving forward.
And you know with the
theme of the podcast, too,
all those tie into mental health.
All the pieces that you're
bringing up, if those are lost,
that's when people start
to get frayed, in a sense,
because everything we're
talking about, I mean,
all these, they're emotionally
heavy, they're taxing.
I mean, A.D. you've written
about the racial trauma,
you've talked about that
quite a bit as well.
And when we don't have that
community and that purpose
I guess it's that much easier
for those challenges to emerge
and then to people, again,
to lose track of really being centered
and having that place and those tools.
Because, you know, I mean, this is,
sounds like a cliche, but when people
spread themselves too thin
and don't attend to themselves
then they can't help anybody else.
If they're not in a place
of wholeness themselves,
and that's not to say that we
have to be completely whole
to engage, but we can't
ignore it, obviously,
and think that we're going to be
effective in other people's lives.
- No, that's good.
- Yeah, you know, I have
this view that, you know,
we're, all of us, inevitably,
will lose our way.
That's just what it means
to be human, you know?
The temptations will be what they are.
And, you know, the
thing is that, you know,
passing the mic is hard when
people are giving it to you,
over and over and over again.
Trying to anoint you, trying
to make you the spokesperson,
make you the, you know,
always that article, the,
not a, but the, right?
And so when you lose your
way, 'cause you will,
the question is what do
you have to recalibrate,
to recenter?
- I like that.
- And so I'm my momma's child.
I'm Juanita Glaude's child.
Juanita had her first
baby in the ninth grade,
she was cleaning toilets for a living,
then became a supervisor
of the janitorial crew
at the English shipyard, right?
So whenever I lose my way,
I have something to
recenter, to recalibrate,
who am I in relation
to that representative,
that representation of value
who's at the core of who I am.
So when people don't have
the ability to recalibrate,
that's when they become
dangerous, you see.
So I think this, 'cause, you know,
I'm skeptical of wholeness.
You know, I use the analogy
of kintsugi pottery,
you know, the Japanese
pottery where, you know,
you can have a crack, it's
a cracked piece of pottery,
right, but they fill it with gold.
The crack doesn't disappear.
So the cracked pot is
actually more valuable
than the original version.
So I don't like to aspire for wholeness.
I want to find beauty in my brokenness.
- That's good.
- 'Cause, you see what
I'm, does that make sense?
I'm speaking to the
neuroscientist now, so-
(all laughing)
Trying to-
- You're good, you're good.
- All right, all right, A.D., you see,
I'm gonna back up off that one now.
I'm gonna leave it alone 'cause he's like
let me break this down for you.
- No, you're good.
I mean, everything that
comes from the pain too.
- Exactly!
- Of moving forward.
'Cause we always talk about
that with broken bones,
but there are ways that that
happens with our brains too.
I mean, there are all the processes
and developmental processes
we go through and, you know,
people like to throw
around the word plasticity,
but just the changes that
can happen to our brains
when we go through certain circumstances.
Some of that plasticity can happen
through painful circumstances.
And it's an ongoing process
that happens with the good things,
that happens with the bad things,
and that all gets us to
a place where we are now.
So it's not to say that we avoid the pain,
and I mean, if we're thinking
in terms of psychology,
that's kind of that
cliche of avoid avoidance.
So if have to deal with something,
you need to deal with
it and move through it.
If you avoid it, it's
just going to fester.
And so you have to, I mean,
there's pain that comes with that,
there's brokenness that comes with that,
but we get to a stronger place
of healing on the other side,
we learn those skills, so.
I'll give you that neuroscience
validation for you.
(all laughing)
- I like that.
- A.D. were you gonna respond there too?
Before I pulled in neuroscience.
- No, no, no, just double click.
(all laughing)
And say that, you know,
that personality generation, you know,
looking to be a personality,
they don't show the cracks and the flaws.
And so we really basically following
a bunch of personalities, really people
who don't display their humanity.
And we're wondering why
we feel more depressed
or more stressed out because,
and this is where it gets
into filmmaking for myself,
we're imitating a false reality, you know?
And so we want to challenge people
to tell honest stories
about vices and virtues
and only follow those
things that are honest
in their vices and
honest in their virtues.
So even if you see me
do something virtuous,
don't assume inside, 100%,
I was clear from not
trying to come up, right?
(chuckles) It's always
a wrestle, you know?
So I like that, you know,
somebody's too whole, you know,
it's like we say in the street,
if somebody is so perfect, it's like,
man, I can't trust you.
(all laughing)
- What's going on here?
Absolutely, doc.
- Yeah, I wanted to kind of
loop back into this idea to,
you know, pay just everything
that you've done around,
you know, with your studying and reading
and teaching on James Baldwin and,
not in a downplaying
way, but the messiness
of everything that he went through.
It's not pain-free, I mean, you know,
all the challenges that
you've talked about,
the intersection of just
the mental health challenges
and the activism, and I just
wonder if you could elaborate
on just what you've
learned in that journey,
even after you've been talking about
this challenge of
wholeness and the cracks,
and as we talked about the neuroscience
of importance of walking through pain.
What has that journey been like for you
in terms of understanding from history
what others have had to go through
even to try and affect change?
- You know, when I was
working on my book on,
Begin Again with Baldwin, you know,
the sentences initially didn't dance.
And I remember hearing Jimmy
say something in my head,
you know, well, if we're gonna
do this together, old boy,
you're gonna have to deal with you.
And so I had to go back
and deal with the fact that
I'm still, you know, I
still got daddy issues.
That I'm still this wounded little boy,
and once I started
grappling with, you know,
my own relationship with my father,
the sentences started jumping.
So Baldwin says you can't
run away from your fears,
you've got to run towards it.
It's a sign of maturity.
And what he's saying is that
the messiness of American life
is actually a reflection of the messiness
of our interior lives.
So that unexamined life,
to use Socrates', you know, dictum,
the unexamined life isn't
worth living, right,
but the unexamined life
also generates a world,
you know, that puts us all in peril.
And so part of what I learned,
'cause Jimmy was always
on the verge of disaster.
You know he tried to commit suicide twice,
he was drowning himself in alcohol.
I barely survived writing the book
because he was demanding so much of me.
And it wasn't until, I'll say this,
it wasn't until I saw, I read it,
I saw an exchange between
him and Nikki Giovanni.
- Oh my goodness.
- And Nikki Giovanni, A.D.,
and Jimmy was Jimmy Baldwin at this point,
and Nikki Giovanni's a young
sister, up and coming poet.
And she was like, Baldwin
was talking about, you know,
black men having to go to
work and dah, dah, dah,
and come home, and she says lie to me.
- Yes.
- And Baldwin's confused.
(A.D. laughing)
She says, lie to me.
You come home and you take
it out on me, lie to me.
And it was in that moment, that exchange,
where Baldwin's demand for
a certain kind of honesty
that was almost tearing
my world apart, right,
came into view in a different sort of way.
Nikki gave me license to
hold him at arms length
to a certain degree.
But at the end of the day, doc,
a certain kind of maturity
requires confrontation
with who you are, so that you
can actually release yourself
into who you can be.
And Baldwin would take that formulation
and apply it to the nation.
Unless you confront who you are for real,
you're never gonna become
anything otherwise.
You know, so that's the formulation, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, no, that's so good,
so many parallels there.
And I mean, to be honest, that's something
I'm continuing to try to
just, to wrestle with.
You know, even the parallels,
not to take it too far,
but about the state of our country
and how we think about mental health.
That aspect of denial that's there
and the challenge of addressing something
when you're in denial.
So, you know, I was
mentioning that whole thing
about avoidance, so, you know,
if people are going through anxiety
the key is to not avoid
getting into the situation.
'Cause it's just gonna
get bigger and bigger
in your mind, it's gonna
be that much harder
to deal with it the next time,
and just all the parallels
that come up between those two.
I haven't quite formulated it yet,
but it's still, and you've
mentioned that as well,
just the danger, just the
danger of living in that space
and I'm sure, maybe
we'll come back to that
in terms of the commentary
on the country too.
But A.D. I want to give you
a chance to kind of respond
to what, all this truth that
Eddie's dropping as well.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, no, I mean that,
I can speak from that.
First of all the Nikki Giovanni
James Baldwin interview,
that is like on the top five-
(all laughing)
Just pieces that you need to consume.
It was phenomenal.
And like he said, with
Baldwin being Baldwin
and she being the up and coming,
but she challenged him.
Showed me a lot about who she still is
and who we need to be as people,
like don't get caught
up in this personality
but look at who they are.
Is this right, is this wrong,
does it need to be challenged?
And I think, you know, going to his point,
we take on so many, I would
say lies and deceptions
that we aren't strong
enough to run into the thing
we fear most and come out
and to make it out on the other end.
I can't tell you the
number of people who say,
yeah man, I get what you saying A.D.,
about, you know, facing the fears
and you gotta deal with the trauma,
but I don't know if I'm gonna
make it on the other side.
And my response is, what
a low view of yourself
and what a low view of humanity
that you don't believe
you have the strength
to make it through this pain
that isn't supposed to be
the marker of who you are.
So I'll go, if I'm telling you, yo,
you can actually heal from this.
Yeah, but I'm used to work
working with this broken arm.
But you know it can be healed and better
if we break it, and I get that.
But I don't know if I'm
gonna make it through
the other side of that,
the other side of the pain.
And a lot of times I'm thinking, wow,
what has convinced us of that?
That's a huge presupposition.
And so I'm always challenging
people to be more inspired,
to be more aspiring of themselves
and to reject these false narratives that,
this low place or low station that we have
is where we're supposed to just
survive through life, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
Surviving versus thriving.
But it is not easy, as you mentioned too,
just, and we'll get back to some of the,
what you brought in your book too,
but just all the traumas
that people go through
and just all the lack of
control that comes with that.
So in some ways I think sometimes there is
a false sense of safety, and
not minimizing it at all,
but a false sense of safety
in not moving forward
because at least then people feel like
they can control that aspect,
versus going through to a place
where they may not have control,
again, all the challenges
come through that.
I mean, there's obviously ways
that trauma counselors and folks
can help people through that,
but I think that's a key piece as well,
but I think it's so important
that you bring that to people
and show what is on the other side,
'cause it gets back to
that idea of the pain too,
and how much stronger we are
when we go through the pain.
I'm gonna stay in my
lane in the neuroscience
and not try and venture out,
but there is truth to it.
- Say one thing on that?
I think also, I'll speak
directly to, you know,
African-American descendants of slaves.
I will speak directly to this.
We downplay the fact that
we tangibly made it through
what I would call some of the
most hellacious, terrorizing,
and inhumane tangible things.
We don't even have to talk
about the actual morality of it,
I'm just talking about physically.
And that came to light
when I was able to do
this documentary in Ghana and I physically
were in these places
where you couldn't see
the light of day for months on end,
we're talking about a different level
of solitary confinement, right?
You stand there and you go,
there's no way there should
be a physical person,
we ain't even got to the boats,
we're talking about the
processing castles, right?
And then you go before
the processing castles
the 500 mile journey
and you go, we had to,
we, our, my ancestors did this too?
So when you come through all that you go,
I don't know what it is,
I don't know how I'm gonna get there,
but I've been born to triumph.
My people, my specific
people, are born to triumph.
It may be Jay Z, we may not
know what the tools are,
but I do know this: I'm born to triumph.
And that's something, as
I look at us as brown men,
I'm like, nah, I ain't believing that lie.
- Yeah.
For real, for real, real talk.
- Real talk.
- Eddie, anything you want to follow up?
That powerful statement?
- Yeah, you know, I used to say to my son,
I didn't used to say,
I say it all the time
and I say it to myself:
the world conspires to make you small.
And the question you have to ask yourself
is will you be complicit?
- Come on (laughs).
- And if you're not gonna be complicit,
then you must do like John
Coltrane, take giant steps.
So, you know what I mean?
So I think, and you know, one
way to render A.D.'s point
is that we all were born with
a crown above our head, man.
The question is will you grow into it?
Will you grow into it?
And part of the challenge
we face over and over again
is getting people to see that.
Because again, the world
tries to make a small.
'Cause you got some folks
in the most cosmopolitan city in the world
can't see beyond their
borough, their neighborhood.
I'm not talking about folk in the Delta,
I'm talking about folk in New York.
Talking about folk in Chicago,
talking about folk in Los Angeles, right?
So there's a sense in which,
to understand one's life
as the canvas to create art,
to create beauty, right,
no matter the circumstance,
is a challenge, is hard to do.
So how do we break through
that is the question, you know?
But I have no, I don't
want to be complicit.
I'm gonna sound like Melville,
Melville's Bartleby the
Scrivener: I prefer not to.
(all laughing)
- So good.
- That's good.
- I'm still, I mean, I'm
still harping back to my,
just the community part and A.D.
I'm still feeling that
like what are the steps,
what are the steps?
(all laughing)
But I think, I mean, in some ways it's a,
even the way you described
that with your son,
like and the influence that you mentioned
that each of us have in the interactions,
in our spheres of influence,
and the impact of having
those conversations
and building that sense of community
even one person at a time
I think is so, so powerful.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry, go ahead.
- No, you're good.
- No, I was just thinking
about my son, right?
You know, I remember we were in an airport
when it came, the decision to
not charge the police officers
who could killed Tamir Rice.
And I immediately looked
back to find my son.
Six two, he was at the time, you know,
a D1 prospect for basketball,
and I'm looking at him
and he's pacing around the
airport like a caged panther.
And I'm trying to figure out
how do I keep this rage from
taking root in his spirit?
How do I keep, you know, the
anger from turning on him?
Right?
And part of what I was
trying to do at the time,
and I failed miserably on certain levels,
was to really to get him
to understand himself
in relation to others, right?
Not to let the anger take root in here,
but to really use it as a way to motivate
changing the world as such.
And again, that requires this
I-thou relationship, right?
That requires to, for
him to think of himself
in more expansive terms and the like.
But you know, it was a challenge, doc.
It was a challenge.
'Cause we both were pacing like panthers,
to be honest with you.
- Yeah, and I appreciate your honesty too
and voicing the challenge
and what you had to help him walk through.
I mean, I'm thinking of
just so many folks who,
you know, we've been doing
that in so many different ways,
and I would say the one thing
that's been really encouraging
and this community idea
keeps coming up too,
but the way that people were able to
not only just internalize
it but to externalize it
and to build community with that.
So you know even within neuroscience,
by the time this airs this
will be a couple of weeks out,
but there's a black and neuro
event that's been going on.
That started from one
student's tweet a year ago.
Now they have 20,000 followers on Twitter.
They've done 56 events in the last year.
And just the way that they've been able
to galvanize a community,
as students, as trainees,
because they took that pain
and tried to build something with it,
rather than just getting
stuck in themselves
even though that would be so easy to do.
But just, not that it's
a solution to everything,
but there's been so much that's happened
because of that movement.
People who, you know, all
the things that happen
with people being in
predominantly white spaces
feeling like they're the only one,
like people being able
to say, oh, I didn't know
there was this person here,
there's this person here,
and being able to connect in that way
and just what that has been in terms of
just people's day to day,
the encouragement
they've gotten from that.
So I think, you know that,
to me that's been just
a great example of seeing the
young people just rising up
and moving forward in
the midst of the pain.
- That's wonderful.
- It's been encouraging.
- All right, here you go, I got you.
First step, you gotta know
history and know your history.
I think that's very important.
Even down to the fact of, I,
when I started taking this journey,
I started asking my mom, what happened,
what was happening to you while
you were pregnant with me?
A lot of people don't know those things.
And I uncovered a key
story, 'cause my life
has also been marked by
everything just felt like a fight.
Though I grew up in Detroit
and things were crazy,
everything just felt like a fight.
Like why does everything feel so hard?
And she told me a story
recently that shocked my mind.
She goes, well son, I was
waiting to tell you this,
you know, when your mom says, oh, okay
what she about to tell me (laughs)?
She says at the time medicine
wasn't as advanced as it is now,
and a doctor turned and
said to me, she says,
if your son doesn't figure out
how to come through this canal,
'cause we can't grab
him or we'll kill him,
if he doesn't figure out how
to come through this canal,
you both will die.
Think about that.
So I go that makes sense.
She said, so you've had to
figure out things with no manual
even before you took your first breath.
- Wow.
- Now that explains a lot.
So I'm like thank you for the story mom
but why you ain't tell me this earlier?
But praise God, you know?
(all laughing)
But that gives context now to
why life has felt like a struggle
though there's been triumphs.
Those are the stories we need to uncover
in our personal lives
and our historical lives.
I'll give you another that
helped me from Ida B. Wells.
When I realized her suffrage,
not only trying to get
people to understand
the tragedy of lynching
in the white church,
but then the pushback she
got in the black church,
I go, oh, this helps me understand
what we would be up against,
even in showing people
the humanity of truth
some people are going, yeah,
we just want to stay undercover though.
Don't shine the light on the truth
'cause it may affect the thing
we're surviving with, right?
So those things help.
So your history, understand history,
and then the last thing I would say
that people don't want to do,
and you got to do it daily,
they don't want to name
the things that pain them.
So that could be in a daily thing like
hey babe, when you said that, that hurt.
Hey son, when you treated me like that
in front of the other parents, that hurt.
I remember I had to have a conversation
with my daughter as, I think
she was eight years old,
we were at a tennis
tournament, and I didn't react
but I pulled it to her
side, I said, babe, hey,
the way you're treating me,
it feels like I'm doing
nothing for you as a parent.
That hurts.
Now, is that where I come from?
No!
I had to learn that.
But that helped her understand
that dad is a person in his emotions,
and then that helps
her know how to process
and flesh out her emotions.
- Wow.
- That's so good.
I was gonna say, that
took a lot of bravery
on your part too.
- Indeed.
- And not be the black parent like, oh,
oh so this is what you got?
(all laughing)
- Bring your little, come here!
Snatch you off the court.
(all laughing)
- But there's so much
teaching that you did
in that moment too.
- Absolutely.
- For her.
Just to be able to show that example
of the importance of naming it.
Being able to address it head on, so.
Yeah, so good.
Well, I'm not leaving much
time to talk about the country,
but I did want to pull
that in just a little bit
in terms of, I mean, all the things
that we've brought up that
I think are so important
and talking about those
aspects of community
and what we do, staying in our lane,
our interaction, spheres of influence.
But when it comes to
the country as a whole,
where are we in this state of denial
versus really trying
to move things forward?
'Cause I know we don't have time
to get into all the details,
but even all the conversations
around critical race theory,
which of course it's based
more on the law school setting
seems to be getting
blown up and pushed back
and all these different types of things
and Eddie I've heard
you say that, you know,
some of the pushback has been an attempt
to arrest what we thought
was a genuine racial
reckoning in this country.
So I'm just curious to
know, as we wrap up,
like what your, just
what your thoughts are
about where we are as a country
and what we really need
to do to move this forward
as we talked about the personal community,
but how do we change
where we are as a nation?
- Well, I think, you
know, we're in real time
experiencing the reassertion of the lie.
At every single time,
at every single moment
when the nation is on the cusp
of fundamentally grappling
with the central contradiction
that threatens democracy, the nation,
white people in particular,
they double down on the ugliness,
and we're seeing it in
real time right now.
You know, I'm from the
coast of Mississippi
so I know a little bit about hurricanes.
You know, the front end of
a hurricane is very violent,
tears up everything, but
then there's the eye,
and then you come, the
eye allows you to come out
and assess the damage,
but the tail is coming
and the tail is as bad as the front end.
The tail is still coming y'all.
So we're at a crossroads and I'm not sure
if we double down on
the ugliness this time,
whether or not the nation will survive,
to be honest with you.
- And what do you, give
me, need some thoughts.
When you say double down on the ugliness?
- The idea that this
must be a white nation
in the vein of old Europe.
So they're gonna disenfranchise folk,
they're gonna, you know,
at the moment in which
we were trying to address
policing in the country,
passing just something
that was really baseline,
the George Floyd Justice and Policing Act,
they're already trying to
pull back qualified immunity.
They're trying to gut it.
And at the same time that
they're trying to gut it,
they're now trafficking in the language
of the increase in violent
crime as a justification
to redouble the efforts that led
to the carceral state in the first place.
So we're in the midst of a
reassertion of a way of being
and the people who are doing it
don't give a damn about democracy.
So the two of them,
these things converging,
I don't know if this place will survive,
to be honest with you, if they do it.
I don't know if we will survive
it, to be honest with you.
- No, it's good.
You know, it's interesting you say that,
'cause a friend's been on my head to watch
this docu-series called
How to Become a Dictator,
How to be a Dictator on Netflix.
In episode one talks exactly
about what you're talking about
and why dictator's rise is because
they say what a lot of people
actually feel and want.
And you're seeing it 'cause, you know,
people are like, man, how is this?
And they go, no, it's been there.
They just needed someone
they can get behind.
- Exactly.
- And that's where we are.
- Yeah, but you know,
as Baldwin would say,
human beings are miracles and
disasters at the same time.
We have to protect ourselves
from the disasters that we've become,
but if we show up, if we all
show up and risk everything,
there's a chance for a miracle.
So we just need to show up.
- Yeah, and that's good.
I mean that was gonna be my next question,
do we have hope in the
midst of everything?
- Yeah, you know, Baldwin,
I'm quoting Baldwin again,
Jimmy has this wonderful line, he says,
he has this wonderful line, doc,
he says hope is invented every day.
And if hope is invented
every day that means
you've beaten back despair every day.
So yeah, yeah, we got hope.
We got to have hope in us.
We're not naive, it's a
blues soaked hope, doc.
- I'll take it, I'll take it.
And to pull in the psychology
and neuroscience again,
just 'cause that's who I am-
- Come on man, bring it in.
- I think there's so
much evidence from that,
you know, as people, if we
just talk about therapy,
if people are going through
therapy, if they have hope,
they're that much more
likely to get through
and get to a place of healing.
Maybe not wholeness or complete healing,
but to actually be able to
move through in that place
and then from a neuroscience perspective,
just that expectation,
what that does to our brains
and the way our brains
process different situations.
So I think that hope is
key in a lot of ways.
And there's just so much evidence for that
so it's something that we gotta hold onto.
Maybe I need to start pulling in Baldwin
in some of my neuroscience courses too.
Tie those two together.
(all laughing)
- What are you thinking, A.D.?
What do you think?
- Yeah, you know, I'm
always gonna default to
a hope that's tangible
and a hope that's honest.
And I think in order for us to survive,
we have to have an honest hope
and I would agree with Eddie
that the lie is resurfacing,
and sometimes you have
the lie of a false hope,
and that's what becomes
dangerous, you know?
Now I'm gonna say this
as a person of color
and you know, on the heels
of reading Caste, the book,
I actually think people
who know true oppression
know what true hope is.
And in those darkest moments,
you'll see those people being the ones
that are leaned upon
because we actually know
our way through the darkness, right?
So that's the, when I have hope I go,
man we were born for something,
we were born for dark days,
and when those dark days
come, they're gonna come.
I hope we are united enough as
people to lead the right way.
- That's some fresh work.
- Well said, well said.
Well I appreciate both
of you being on here
and so much truth and so much
richness in this conversation.
We've covered a lot of ground
in that short period of time.
And I'm grateful for the both of you,
I know this will be a
blessing to listeners as well
and encourage people to continue
wrestling with these topics as we all seek
to move forward into a better place.
Thanks again to both of you
for jumping on The Addy Hour,
definitely appreciate
it, appreciate your time.
- Appreciate you, doc.
- Yeah, likewise, appreciate it.
(serious hip hop music)